[Music]
our bezel is future has finally arrived
kinda sorta hey what's up guys I'm cabby
HD here and remember that VEVO apex
concept phone we saw a couple of weeks
ago at that trade show it was a concept
phone meaning it's never gonna go on
sale they only made a couple it's more
like a working prototype but it was a
vision or this idea of technologies that
could come to eventually be more
affordable but sure enough a couple
weeks later vivo said wait hold that
thought
we're actually gonna make a real phone
that we're going to go on sale with
that's just almost there almost there it
has a lot of the same technologies from
that concept phone that's gonna be
brought down into something that we can
actually sell so that's how we got this
vivo NEX
or any ex I'd consider this the closest
thing we have to an actual bezels phone
right now so just opening up the box and
looking at it for the first time it is
pretty striking this is that
nationalists phone people have been
clamoring for and honestly the phone
I've been wanting the future to bring
since we started getting notches in the
first place this one happens to be a six
point six inch 1080p Super AMOLED
display and it's a little taller than
sixteen by nine it's 19.3 by nine has
these well rounded corners that we're
seeing in every phone now and with these
super thin bezels you end up with a
ninety one point two four percent screen
to body ratio so cracking that holy
grail ninety percent number highest I've
seen in a real phone here and I think
it's pretty sick it does have the looks
it's not perfect but the top bezel is
tiny the side bezels are about the same
as what we see in a lot of other phones
now and then a little bit more of a chin
than the concept phone you get about a
five millimeter chin at the bottom looks
pretty similar to what we have in like a
one plus six maybe even a little bit
smaller than that but I have no problems
holding it even though it's a huge
display my hand doesn't really touch the
edges but if it does the accidental
touch rejection is on point this is
truly the most screen we have in any
phone but that actually brings us to the
question what about all the stuff that's
normally on the front of the phone what
about the front facing sensors what
about the stuff that's normally in the
knotch where that I'll go and that's
where you get those apex concept phone
technologies trickling down in this one
already so number one is that
fingerprint sensor and this is the under
glass fingerprint reader that I've
tested
to the max in a previous video same deal
here no fingerprint reader anywhere else
on this phone is just under the glass at
the front with all the pros and cons
that come with that in 2018
so you know a little slower a little
more finicky but definitely cleverly
hidden for this concept and then number
two the front-facing camera where is
that this one is actually hidden just
like the apex concept phone it's in this
mechanically retracting chassis that
slides up and down whenever it's needed
and makes this noise in the process now
that might seem a little cheesy but you
can actually choose between three
artificial noises you can pick your
favorite or you can just leave it silent
so that that that's the front-facing
camera that's what happens every time
you want to take a selfie every time
snapchat opens every time you want to do
an Instagram live all that the concern
naturally with this is that it's a
moving part phones normally don't have
moving parts so normally completely
solid-state for things like
waterproofing and durability
that kind of stuff here is probably a
little bit questionable you know if you
drop this while the camera is out does
it just snap off you know something
happens in your pocket it gets scratched
what if the app freezes or the mechanism
fails what if someone pushes back
against it all that stuff of course has
probably been tested by the Evo but you
never really know what might happen in
real life
and I got to be honest I wasn't even
expecting the camera to be that great
but it looks pretty good on the phone
like it isn't a phone that's gonna be
coming to the US as far as I can tell
it's just China but there's a lot more
to this phone than just the design and
the rest is pretty solid too like you
might remember when I first heard about
this phone i tweeted like the rest of it
could be trashed but the design is still
really cool but this is this is a full
flagship from vivo so this is getting
the full treatment this is snapdragon
845 inside eight gigabytes of ram 256
gigs of storage and a four thousand
milliamp hour battery it's like
everything lenovo wanted to be seems
like a pretty quality pair of dual
cameras on the back it's 12 megapixel
primary and 5 megapixels and they're in
this super shiny rainbow reflective
metallic type of material they actually
named it they call it
graphic diffraction dynamic color
illusion technology it still has a
headphone jack it is a dual SIM card
tray at the bottom as well it has this
AI button vivo software is pretty
specific like it's not my cup of tea
it's not for this market obviously so a
lot of stuff isn't even English here but
overall like I said it's a real honest
flagship and I'd love to see them
actually try to make and sell a US
version 100% but yeah let me know if
this is this the future we asked for is
this how bad we hate the notch that
we're willing to go to mechanical moving
parts to get rid of it
hit me with those comments let me know
what you think also definitely check out
my two other videos that are pretty
specific to this phone and possibly
another one upcoming but I've done the
English fingerprint reader tested to the
max to the extreme I'll link that below
that like button and there is also a
video all about notches and how that
technology is shifting towards this
either way thanks for watching talk to
guys the next one peace